foreign
[Music]
guy one more trip down the evercliched
interstellar birth canal
can you check my language settings while
cursing the franchise for so few of
these interesting training scenes enough
to get by
hmm Hey listen to your discount davros
not every Droid in this series needs to
be in competition for the title of Sassy
one how about Satoshi for a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away there are
certainly a lot of references to a
Japanese culture that hasn't even
existed yet a skill with a weapon comes
from your Mandalorian of Brittany
those skills alone will not be enough to
defeat our enemy denjarin has entered
the chat and would appreciate it if he
kept the name of his people out of your
mouth also citing this need for
the force is the most Star Wars thing to
ever Star Wars we already have enough
Force users just let her wield
lightsabers chew bubble gum and kick ass
I can't see how am I supposed to fight
if we all know that you're supposed to
use the force here then you should know
that you're supposed to use the force
here do you know where I am next to who
Yang are you sure ah yes that famous
power we so rarely see the force move to
wherever the she needs to while the
camera is in honor I can't wait to see
Sabine master that one sense my
intention my technique for quickly
ending a first date somehow makes its
way into the episode we have former are
Imperials working throughout every level
of the new republic government
they've all taken an oath of loyalty
Senator Rodrigo is either an imperial
loyalist as well or has never heard of
the concept of lying either should
disqualify her from being a senator yes
but I believe their activity speaks to a
larger operation going with this instead
of saying they stole a big
Engine That Could be used to build a big
weapon isn't this just another
attempt to gain New Republic resources
to Aid in what has ultimately been your
personal quest to find Ezra Bridger we
haven't seen Harry be obsessed with
searching for Ezra in this series but
none of these other politic heads
questions the owner's assertion so he
may have a point but we have no evidence
in either direction yeah and in spite of
that I hate this guy and fully support
Hera that's manipulation and I fear a
Sith scribe may be behind all of this
where did you hear that Chopper told me
word on the street is the Choppers
committed several war crimes you know
just things to consider before enlisting
them for babysitting Duty I was hoping
that the urgency of our situation could
expedite my training a bit what does
that even mean and why does Sabine think
that that's something that could even
happen you spend five minutes on any
group project with a Jedi and you can't
talk pretty quickly that this is going
to be a long drawn out process with no
distinct beginning or end they're not
even sure what the goal is half the time
how do you expect them to expedite it
Talent is a factor but training and
focus are what truly Define someone's
success that is a lesson for the kids
and any adults whose spirit is not yet
broken so the sin is just the kids
because the latter do not exist the Jedi
Order would not have accepted her she is
not an acceptable candidate by their
standards standards which were proven
over a millennia
and failed and failed doesn't quite
capture being overthrown by the most
obviously evil dude hiding in plain
sight and a whiny kid with daddy issues
I suppose you do come from a long line
of non-traditional Jedi and if you don't
get what that means stop the show here
and go watch 170 hours of previous Star
Wars content to catch up don't worry
we'll wait mocking me for the thing I do
at least three times a day to test my
own Force sensitivity the difference is
when Sabine does IT staff doesn't throw
pencils at her and she'll get back to
work we've entered the denap system all
com Transmissions are being jammed all
the calm transmissions for the entire
system while in a hyperspace Lane is it
possible maybe is it convenient radio
definitely try to drop out of
hyperspace so far from the planet well
Productions cooked up a cool space
battle to spice up this procedural
walkthrough of a plot standard Jedi
Mission protocol When approaching an
unknown situation you say Malu run I say
I'm a low run it's getting us in either
way over price C-3PO tell them please it
took three episodes for the series to
fight finally show us its ball turret
see you got rid of my presets I never
needed them come on no one ever deletes
presets leave them there to languish for
an eternity and a Restless Slumber this
is so much like World War II air battle
that it doesn't feel like space at all
is there air we don't know lucky or
unlucky for Sabine all the fighters seem
dead set on flying directly at the tail
Gunner position feast or famine am I
right
this is only episode three you can panic
when they're still doing this by
episode seven or eight
dive has a directional command makes
very little sense in space and is not
nearly as sexy as change orientation
with a 90 degree pitch down maneuver
using a propulsive burn we got two more
incoming dead ahead and given the fact
that no forward weapons are fired I
guess this ship has no front guns and
given the fact that these Fighters hit
absolutely nothing I guess their former
Stormtroopers
and murder is fun a scene why are you
being this way I am starting to receive
data title of my Trex tape how
interesting I would never have guessed
it oh pray tell I'm on the edge of my
seat and will remain so until I get all
the hot gas I'm sure the show wouldn't
make me wait another eight minutes for
the hot gas deflectors of 10 using math
to tell me the situation is dire
destroyed we'll get the force out of
here with this brief moment it did the
title character just die in episode
three just force right off with that
bantha fodder this ship is
damaged and not moving they don't need
to keep flying by so fast like that pump
the brakes and line up your shot also
can Ahsoka even get The High Ground in
outer space damn prequel memes some
reddits have ruined me
oh well that was pretty freaking cool go
ahead take your sim back a lot of effort
was just put into trying to kill Ahsoka
instead of blowing up the ship and that
made no sense forget about the Eagles I
want to know why they didn't fly the
pergola to Mordor just kidding I know
this is an Harry Potter I've got no
we all do Everybody Poops they must be
hiding in the forest let's regroup
episode takes the idea of scanning for
life forms or heat signatures out of its
pocket and looks at it fondly for a
second and then throws it out of the car
onto the highway just like I did with my
brother's baseball glove when I was five
crowd with these power levels and
configuration would be capable of a
hyperspace jump
astonishing speed and distance like it's
worried about Kessel running itself into
a corner the Jedi
Lanes between galaxies which used to
follow the migration plots of star
whales named Pearl Droid splaining your
Jedi archives position Jedi have taken
refuge in the forest hunt them down I'm
going to keep staring at this hinge
because rocks man how do they work
what if I won again all com
Transmissions are being jammed or in
conversation anyway
great kid don't get cocky
if I had to guess I would say it is some
sort of hyperspace ring or NuvaRing
there they are they're listening lazily
to the left go left left we're fast I'm
going out there you're gonna do what
there is
Colonia on the wing
see her
we're not here